je vous trouve sur wiiu place de botton
points comme avec un axe hors du commun
c'est parce que commence avec un dilemme
très profond tu peux percevoir toutes
les couleurs et qu'aucun autre humain ne
peut voir mais tu es un papillon
benjamin puis pas du tout sur le bouton
voilà tu sera l'une des meilleures
personnes de ce monde des plus jolies
mais tu sentiras le caca banon qui
aimeraient 23 % des gens ont appuyé dans
mes carnets la même tête assumer
assumons nous comme on est bordé al
awaja me guy qui dit bah je me parfume
et ses finitions plus kaka il a pas tord
tu peut absorber tout le savoir d'un
bouquin juste en le touchant mais tu as
des migraines tous les jours j'appuie
j'appuie comme ça je lis le guide de
world of warcraft et je deviens un
premier joueur mondial a les la moitié
des jours appuyé aux puces pour de vrai
ce but c'est abassi faites travailler
vos neurones un peu apprenez normal tu
peux te transformer en qui tu veux mais
la personne dans laquelle tu transformes
se retrouver avec ton corps après dans
mon cas dans mon cal très pas grand
chose
elle serait là dans un conte position
foetale accords de l'âge c'est rentable
j'appuie tu peux jouer aux jeux vidéo
toute la journée ou mais tu tomberas
tout le temps quand tu prendras des
escaliers je m'en bats les c
moi je joue déjà je vis de toute la
journée la moitié des gens appuient
quand même c'est pourquoi c'est pas
rentable
parce que si tu tombes dans les marchés
tu pètes le poignet bah tu peux plus
jouer aux jeux vidéo tu deviens nyan cat
mais tu dois constamment fichiers d arc
en ciel 44% des gens veulent devenir en
haleine 4 m
c'est vous dire la vie de merde qu'on a
tu sais tout mais tu devra prendre des
décisions comme si tu n'étais au courant
de rien c'est une torture à tort imagine
tu sais qui va se passer un truc affreux
et tu peux pas le contrôler ce que tu
dois prend une décision comme si tu
savais pas que ce truc à l'arrivée cette
froide est beaucoup trop longue suivants
avoir une prime de 1000 $ tous les mois
mais devoir manger des ramène trois fois
par jour à quel moment c'est un problème
de manger les ramènent trois fois par
jour naruto et dans ce corps hâlé
j'appuie tout de suite 67% des jeux à 1
puis bah oui tous des ninjas [ __ ]
c'est qu'à cacher il a appuyé les buts à
l'heure il a même dit que cette blague
était pas drôle le mariage gay devient
légal c'est déjà le cas mais les
républicains protestent en bannissant le
bacon de toutes les boutiques à tancer
d'une pierre deux coups les homosexuels
sont super contents parce qu'ils peuvent
se marier et en plus le taux d'obésité
baisse c'est vraiment parfait j'appuie
tout de suite à temps là on a dit la
cultre à des bills une personne de ton
choix meurt instantanément mais tout le
monde saura que tu l'as fait ça
s'appelle un crime
c'est vraiment ça t'a rien ce dilemme
c'est coupe la tête haute et ville hôte
en prend tous couteau tuer la personne
est allée au commissariat parce qu'on
allait un dilemme digne d'un film
hollywoodien très triste tu peux faire
en sorte que la personne dont tu est
amoureuse soit aussi amoureuse de toi
mais il ou elle ne sera jamais heureux
avec toi tu as une vision rayons x au
mais tu dois te glu et les mains et les
doigts ensemble et finalement prier dieu
pour qu'il te d'école ce témoin c'est
drôle
allez on s'amuse de revoir vivent dans
le monde de gta 5 mai tout voir en 8
bits
non tu auras une personnalité incroyable
sur un super beau tu auras un corps
incroyable tous les gens t'aime où es tu
feras que des choses bien mais tu ne
pourras plus jamais écouter de la
musique
oh non ça fait chier pour une seule
chance au petit bonheur non j'appuie pas
cinq autres enfants sont des gens
n'appuie pas et écoute petit poney check
obtint den bosch et de pouvoir écouter
ses chansons tu es maintenant capable de
nager 50 kilomètres par heure
mais quand tu nages suite se transforme
en un animal aquatique aléatoire tu peut
par exemple devenir sage peut aussi
devenir le fameux mort vax voilà après
c'est juste le temps de nager donc oui
je je je j'approuve tu as le travail de
tes rêves mais tu n'auras plus jamais de
vacances je m'en bats les steaks parce
que j'ai dû aller de tout ça c'est grâce
à vous vraiment merci beaucoup je vous
aime vous êtes vraiment les meilleurs
voilà fallait que je fasse une séquence
émotion pour montrer que je suis proche
de mes abonnés je vous aimes tu te
maries avec la personne de tes rêves
mais pourra jamais avoir d'enfant bat
adoptent j'appuie où le problème
être meilleur ami avec ta star préférée
mais ne plus jamais avoir d'autres amis
au revoir groupe non je ne suis pas plus
tard elle 62 % des gens qui appuyait
vraiment moins 1000 personnes qui sont
pas de tester leurs habits actuellement
c'est génial de l'argent infinie et du
pouvoir mais tu perds tes jambes alors
de l'argent infinie et du pouvoir c'est
en traîne toujours de la merde
vraiment c'est sûr et certain non un
genre ta vie tu veux te buter fois
retombée héritage
je veux pas te fais ça y est c'est
décidé je découvre que tes ancêtres sont
des héros et que tu es testing et en
devenir un mettez tout temps comparé à
eux ça ça fait mal à l'égo quand même ça
c'est un peu nul exemple s'il était le
fils de robert downey jr tout le monde
irait tout le temps au ton papa c'est
iron man a un illuminé ou le fiston de
héros mort
regardez le non je refuse ce destin tu
deviens l'humain le plus sexy et
attirant sur terre mais tu es tu et on
mesure maintenant à 15 cm
les grosses têtes et allegro tu étais
moi je dis oui tout tu passes l inverse
c mais tu étais mesure quatre
centimètres mais je suis le mec le plus
sexy de terre là ça ne pose problème
dans son style a pas de souci mais ses
méthodes étaient arrivés là vous-même
gratter le menton et et c'est fou
l'humanité ne se sera jamais d'exister
mais tu m'auras après avoir appuyé sur
le bouton se faire ça quand vous tous je
vais appuyer sur ce maudit bhutto que
votre vie soit longue et pleine de juste
débile des milliers de personnes avaient
appuyé sur le bouton avant moi donc je
me suis sacrifié pour rien chute mais à
joubert tout bas dockers
ouais j'en suis à 37 de sa vidéo sur
appuyez-vous sur le bouton points comme
j'espère qu'elle va plus c'est le cas
n'hésitez pas à toucher mais tu étais de
15 centimètres ça fera plaisir c'est
quand même marrant de rejouer à ces jeux
qu'on faisait qu'on était en primaire
les tu préfères south à houlé ce que tu
fais ça si cc c'est drôle et ça c'est
l'intervention nul va savoir la même
source les deux prochaines réunions
portez vous bien tu as tout et courage
pour la rentrée en fait je sais que vous
avez tous défoncés vous avoir des super
note et que les prochaines vacances vont
arriver super vite
tu sais tout motivé discrètement à la
dre nom de projet d emporter ou bien un
chat bis
oh